TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, and
welcome to Google Games
Chat, Episode 9.
I'm glad we could get started.
Sorry we missed you last week.
We were eating turkey.
So let's start by introducing
our panelists.
Today, to my left, playing
the role of Colt
McCanless is a puppet.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hello, I am
international superstar and
HTML5 advocate, Colt
McCanless.
I can't be with you because
I'm recording an Udacity
course on HTML5 Game
Development.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, I'm glad
we have the puppet, because--
yes?
DAN GALPIN: I must know, Colt,
what big teeth you have.
WOLFF DOBSON: All the better
to eat you with.
[ROAR]
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, and
so to my right, wearing the
panda hat, our special guest
star from the Android Friday
Game Review, Daniel.
Hello, Daniel.
DAN GALPIN: Hello.
Thank you for having me on.
I hear that we're not actually
going to be reviewing Android
games today, so I'm not
sure why I'm here.
But I did bring a hat,
which is more than I
have done in a while.
So, it's good to be here.
TODD KERPELMAN: None of us
really know why we're here.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
that's right.
TODD KERPELMAN: It' a
time-filler, really.
I'm sorry, I should clarify--
Dan Galpin, in case you're
not familiar with him.
I just call him Dan.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: And to my far
right, our not-so-special
guest, John McCutchan.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The
boring one.
TODD KERPELMAN: The boring--
kind of the--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: This is actually
the facial hair
table, on this side.
TODD KERPELMAN: Are
we kind of going--
WOLFF DOBSON: What are
you talking about?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
the body hair table.
WOLFF DOBSON: What are
you talking about?
I'm all facial hair.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true,
but you don't count.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm not very good
at math, but you don't
have to say that.
TODD KERPELMAN: And to my far
left, we have the non-puppet
version of Wolff.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: So, welcome.
WOLFF DOBSON: Thank you, sir.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We got the
Wolffs all around this side.
TODD KERPELMAN: We do.
WOLFF DOBSON: [LAUGHTER]
TODD KERPELMAN: So, we don't
have a demo for this episode,
I'm sort of sad to say.
But maybe instead, I'll just
start by asking you guys--
what did you eat for
Thanksgiving?
Did you make anything?
That's the big question.
So we'll start with Wolff.
WOLFF DOBSON: I made
Nutella-stuffed chocolate chip
cookies, which were hilariously
awesome.
TODD KERPELMAN: Those sound--
you really can't
go wrong with Nutella.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, you
really can't.
And you brown the butter,
and it's ridiculous.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
sounds excellent.
Dan?
DAN GALPIN: So, the only thing
that was pretty interesting at
the Thanksgiving table was a
pumpkin sage soup, which
tasted a lot like a butternut
squash soup, but was slightly
more orange.
So not that exciting.
TODD KERPELMAN: John?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, I don't
make anything for
Thanksgiving.
TODD KERPELMAN: Did
you eat plaid?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
of course.
It's a plaid pie.
DAN GALPIN: A plaid
pie-- the whole--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, I enjoyed
a nice meal, though.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
DAN GALPIN: It is weird, because
we're here at Google,
and my cooking muscles are
completely unused.
TODD KERPELMAN: Atrophied?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, they're
atrophied.
I don't even know what to do
around the kitchen anymore,
it's been so long.
but yeah, Thanksgiving
is a good chance to
break them out again.
And they're all sore
now, though.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, I feel
like at Google we get a lot of
special guests that have written
cookbooks that have
great stuff.
And we end up buying all of
these cookbooks, and at least
for me, I end up not really
cooking much.
DAN GALPIN: But it does
decorate your
shelves in your kitchen.
It makes you look like you
know what you're doing.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's true,
and that's half the battle.
DAN GALPIN: That's
the best part.
TODD KERPELMAN: So with that
said, I think we can go right
into our Five For Five.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: We don't have
a fancy graphic, so puppet--
DAN GALPIN: Do we get puppet
Colt responses?
WOLFF DOBSON: Five for five--
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't know.
We'll have to have to ask
the puppet if he's
got anything to add.
DAN GALPIN: I'm sure
the puppet will.
TODD KERPELMAN: Probably.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, since
the Colt is playing Colt
McCanless, clearly it's
going to say things
like, I love HTML.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
TODD KERPELMAN: Probably,
and report on--
DAN GALPIN: That can just be
the answer to all of the
questions, really.
TODD KERPELMAN: Clearly
the answer is HTML5.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
WOLFF DOBSON: Clearly.
TODD KERPELMAN: And report on
whatever he read, and--
WOLFF DOBSON: Have
you tried Chrome?
It's excellent.
TODD KERPELMAN: Purple Cow.
DAN GALPIN: No, I've
never used Chrome.
Oh wait-- sorry, go on.
TODD KERPELMAN: Actually, so
side note, these Chromebooks--
really cool.
DAN GALPIN: Thumbs up.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
they're really nice.
If you don't have a
Chromebook, you
should look into one.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Are these
the new ones?
DAN GALPIN: These are
the new ones--
they finally got the track
pad right, actually.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, the
track pad's nice.
I feel like if those of you who
have parents that might be
asking for new computers for
Christmas or something, this
is a great notebook for your
parents, particularly if you
plan on spending the holidays
not doing tech support.
DAN GALPIN: I was going to say,
it's the most amazing
thing to actually give a parent
a computer and not
expect to spend years doing
tech support on it.
It's incredible.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: What?
How did you end up sending
email to all
of our friends again?
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so product plug aside--
but I'm serious.
WOLFF DOBSON: That was a
spontaneous product plug.
DAN GALPIN: It is not planned.
We were just using these,
and we were like,
these are really nice.
WOLFF DOBSON: Chrome
is so cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so our first question--
DAN GALPIN: Speaking of product
plug, suppose we live
in a world of Google Fiber,
where everybody has access to
uber-fast internet everywhere,
how does this affect gaming?
TODD KERPELMAN: How does
this affect gaming?
And I'm going to press the Start
button to countdown.
And we'll start with
non-puppet Wolff.
WOLFF DOBSON: Non-puppet
Wolff thinks that
distribution is just over.
You distribute digitally.
And there's been a lot of
controversy about always-on
DRM, things like that.
I'm not sure how I feel
about always-on DRM.
But if you live in a world of
Google Fiber, it's not going
to be laggy, it's not going to
be terrible, it's going to be
just the way you interact with
the internet-- just like you
go to Chrome, just like you go
to any internet service.
Am I wrong, or is local
instillation of things going
to be different?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I would take
it a step further.
It's not just digital
distribution.
It's going to be something
like OnLive.
When you have that kind of
bandwidth and that kind of
latency, why would I ever care
to store anything locally?
I would rather just
have it stream.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I guess--
and I don't know all
of the technical
details behind OnLive.
But it seems like one issue that
even with a super-fast
internet connection you're
never really going to be
addressing is the speed
of light problem.
As far as I know, you can't
increase the speed of light
without messing up time.
WOLFF DOBSON: i was going
to say, that's not true.
You can slow light down by
sending it through water.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
But you can't speed it up.
Maybe if you send it
through a vacuum.
But the problem is yeah, you can
get a whole bunch of data
really fast.
But if you need that less than
100 millisecond delay between
when I press the fire button and
my character fires, how do
you deal with that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I already get
much more lower ping times
than 100 milliseconds today.
I get ping times of 10
milliseconds, easily.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
To be honest, I think it's
somewhere in between.
I really think that the
concept of installing
software goes away.
Whether that software is
physically running on your
machine, or whether it's
actually running on some Cloud
system is really going to depend
on what makes sense for
that piece of software.
But I think there's a lot of
things that are going to be
able to run in the browser just
because you're not going
to have to worry about
actually going off--
it's not going to be slow,
particularly, to
go and fetch textures.
And all you're going to have
is a cache, basically, for
anything you're running.
So I think for distribution
it does eliminate that.
For me, the exciting thing is
that it enables all of these
services which have a high
bandwidth return connection.
If I want to jam with people
or create live videos with
people or do that kind of stuff,
all of those gaming
experiences all of a sudden
become really possible.
There's Jam With Chrome,
but, like, times 100--
that kind of stuff.
Or the YouTube orchestra,
where everyone is really
sitting in a different place
in the world, that kind of
stuff becomes really possible.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean, really,
real-time sharing of the
stream on your screen to
somebody else is--
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: One of the things
that we found with
Hangout Games is that when
people are explaining rules to
each other--
like, oh, we're playing this
board game together, we're
playing "WarLight," we're
playing whatever.
You're like, oh let
me show you.
And you share your screen.
And you're pointing, pointing,
go here, whatever.
And having that be as crystal
clear and as uncompressed as
the thing you're seeing there
is going to make a huge
difference in how people
interact with each
other, how they plan.
If you think about "Call of
Duty" where I can have a
little pop up window that is
what the other guy is seeing,
including his voice stream,
including his face, including
all those things, it's like
"Aliens," where they're all
sitting there looking at the
bank of screens that represent
all the people.
You can do that, and it's not
a hardware headache for your
home machine.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So Todd, coming
back to your point
about latency--
the interesting thing, if you
have an online multiplayer
game and the video is being
streamed to you, then you can
actually co-locate--
all of the people that you're
playing the game with can
possibly be on the same
physical machine.
So the latency, in terms of
client-to-client latency is erased.
And then you only have the
latency of your input control
and the video stream
coming back.
And so that's just one way.
There's no interdependencies
between me and any of the
other players in terms
of getting the video.
But in terms of like, hey, I
think the player is going to
be over here in 10 milliseconds,
if we're all on
the same machine, we could even
be on the same instance
of the game.
DAN GALPIN: Well, you can take
that even back, though.
And If you're running a server,
with this kind of
connection, you can actually
have the server really doing
everything.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, exactly.
DAN GALPIN: And even if it's not
actually streaming video
in both directions, even if
all it's doing is sending
polygon data across, there's a
whole bunch of ways you can
split that.
But I think you're right.
I think it just makes the
whole interactive game--
WOLFF DOBSON: That's a really
interesting thought, where you
actually stream the display list
for your graphics card
over your internet connection.
So it renders really fast and
beautifully on your own machine.
I don't know that that would be
bigger or smaller than just
sending the--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
I don't know.
WOLFF DOBSON: Except that
you're outsourcing.
You don't have to have four
video cards for players on
your server, you just have to
send the display data, and
then the video card will--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You would have
to cache things like the text
buffers and textures.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I think
caching is going to be a huge
part of that, anyway.
Except that you don't have to
sit there and think, oh, I
only have eight gigabytes or ten
gigabytes of space on the
machine, and I want
to play this game.
You're just going to dynamically
stream those
things out.
And if Colt were here, he'd be
all about instant-- oh wait,
Colt is here.
What do you want?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, we
need to ask Colt.
We were actually going
to have six.
WOLFF DOBSON: More Chrome.
Excellent.
Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, I'm
going to stop us there.
WOLFF DOBSON: Curses.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm sorry.
The countdown timer
has spoken.
WOLFF DOBSON: [GROWL]
TODD KERPELMAN: And I'm going to
move to our next question,
which is, so I feel like lately
game releases have
become cultural events.
And they are considered
normal.
It's not like, oh man, look at
all these freaks hanging out
in line for "Call of Duty." It's
like, oh, "Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2" is out--
wait, sorry, "Black
Ops 2" is out.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I
was going to say.
TODD KERPELMAN: "Call of Duty
2," that was a while ago.
WOLFF DOBSON: '02.
TODD KERPELMAN: And it's kind
of considered normal.
And people make jokes about
people are going to call in
sick the next day.
WOLFF DOBSON: "Super Mario
World 4" is coming out.
Sorry.
Yeah, I know what you're
talking about.
TODD KERPELMAN: So yeah,
like that part--
DAN GALPIN: "League
of Legends."
TODD KERPELMAN: Games have
essentially, I think, in many
ways entered the mainstream.
But I still feel like
competitive gaming, gaming as
a spectator sport has not yet
entered the mainstream the way
current sports have.
What do you think the games
industry needs to do to make
gaming as a spectator sport
more mainstream?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, clearly my
answer is more Hangouts.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: But I think there
are a lot of interesting
possibilities for Hangouts
there, where you
can actually have--
if you think of poker.
When you're watching poker on
TV, sometimes they show you
the cards of the guy.
This guy's got these cards, this
guy's got these cards,
and what is he seeing.
If everybody's sitting there
with the camera over their
shoulder, wearing some sort of
thing, or you're seeing their
face from behind the thing, and
you're able to actually
select between all those things
that are around, for
games it's the same thing--
I mean, poker is a game.
For these sorts of things,
I think it's the
same sort of thing.
You're going to be
able to have this
personal connection with--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: it's very
interesting as the audience if
you get to see what the state
of every player's
game view is, right?
And you have that extra bit of
information that the players
competing don't have.
Like, hey, I know that the guy
is actually right around the
corner, and he's going
to fragged.
But he doesn't know this.
So it's very exciting.
DAN GALPIN: I think, definitely,
the key thing
that's missing, honestly, is how
if you look at any sports
cast today, it is so
heavily produced.
You have 10 people that are
all sitting in a room.
You have people that
are grabbing shots.
You have people that are moving
cameras around, all
trying to get you the absolute
best view of what's going on,
including replays and everything
like that.
So to me, it's just honestly
getting the
production values up.
There should be stats coming
up on the screen for every
player, where they've been,
how they've done in these
various matches.
Some of this is already there.
I mean if you actually watch--
WOLFF DOBSON: I was going
to say, if you watched--
when I was in Singapore watching
"StarCraft" on TV, it
was like, holy cow.
I mean, I didn't play a lot of
"StarCraft," but I was glued
to the TV going like,
Zerg rush, Zerg
rush, don't you know?
DAN GALPIN: But I think the
thing that's missing is
actually designing the game so
that it's ready from out of
the box to be used as
a spectator sport.
So all of those controls and
hooks and everything like that
is there, so that it actually is
ready to have that kind of
production in it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, "League of
Legends" is an example of a
game where they've really got
that going, because their
camera is at the 3/4 view--
I'll use my wolf here
as a thing.
It uses a 3/4 view, where it's
like, oh, you can see
everybody, you can see what's
going on. "StarCraft" works in
the same way.
If you've ever watched really
awesome people play
"Counter-Strike," you
don't see anything.
You see just like a
blur of polygons
and occasional gunfire.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, basically
everything is replays in that.
You want to be able to
catch how it's--
TODD KERPELMAN: Do you think
first person shooters just
can't work as a spectator
sport, because the
people that play it--
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, no.
"Halo" has got the new
cinema mode, right?
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
WOLFF DOBSON: And one of the--
I think it was Activision "Call
of Duty," one of those
guys had a way you could
upload videos
and reproduce them.
TODD KERPELMAN: The latest "Call
of Duty," I think, let
you instantly upload your stuff
to YouTube, as I recall.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
And I think that's another
thing that's
going on here, too.
Football games are really big,
but they're really expensive.
And they're hard to produce,
because you've got to get
60,000 people all in the same
place to watch this, and
you've got to fly 200
people around.
An online game that we're
playing competitively doesn't
require that much effort, which
means, I think, you're
going to need a way--
like a cinema mode, or something
like that-- to
assemble highlights and make
it into something.
And then there's got to be
community that cares enough
that they're going to want to
export those to everything.
And I think "League of Legends"
is at that point now
where they have that.
DAN GALPIN: Watching "League of
Legends" [INAUDIBLE], I got
to watch it when I was
at PAX this year.
And it's phenomenal.
It absolutely is an event, the
way they put it together.
I mean, it certainly isn't
lacking production values.
I felt that one of the things
that's problematic with
"League of Legends," even the
way they had it set up, and
that was certainly the best
video gaming watching
experience I've ever had-- is
that I still wanted more
connection with the people who
were actually playing the
game, versus their character
avatars.
When people die, it's got
to be a human thing.
It should be like you're dealing
with a reality show
kind of thing, where you
actually see the superimposed
actual person who's controlling
the player
[INAUDIBLE].
And one thing that would be even
fun as you get further
along is to actually think about
how you map the emotions
of the person who's playing on
to the avatar that they're
controlling.
You actually get some
potentially
interesting things there.
You basically have real-time
versions of "The Polar
Express" or something like that,
where you actually are--
WOLFF DOBSON: You actually see
people's arm gestures and
things like that.
Like, I think that's
the thing--
DAN GALPIN: Ooh, can't
show that on TV.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, well I was
going to say, I mean sort
of along with--
WOLFF DOBSON: Go there
first, huh?
AUDIENCE: You know, we've
got a question.
Now, what about alternate
reality gaming?
Andre's asking about that
from the YouTube side.
TODD KERPELMAN: What
is he asking?
AUDIENCE: Alternate Reality
Gaming, it's called ARG.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, he's
talking about--
I mean "Ingress"
is an examples.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK, like
augmented reality.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or "I Love Bees,"
or something like that,
augmented reality games.
DAN GALPIN: I was thinking
alternate
reality gaming, that's--
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
like "Second Life,"
we're going to have--
WOLFF DOBSON: Pretty
alternate--
no, I think yeah, that's
interesting.
Because I know when "I Love
Bees" was huge, and for those
of you who aren't following the
bee references, that's the
ARG that they made for
"Halo" to try to
get everybody centered.
I forget which "Halo"
release it was.
TODD KERPELMAN: "Halo
2," maybe.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, something
like that, where they were
trying to get everybody into the
backstory of the game, so
that when it came out-- and I
think going to your thing
about these are cultural events,
games that have huge
marketing budgets, their goal is
to make it a giant cultural
event, versus an indie sleeper
hit that's going to--
I'm going to sell this
for seven years.
But yeah, they ended up
assembling a whole website
with everybody, and they had
people reporting back on the
phone calls that were going
out to all weird numbers
around the country.
It was really neat.
I have to admit, I was sort of
overwhelmed by trying to join
that community.
I didn't even know
where to start.
But that was definitely a
place where people were
showing their stuff online.
And I think now that we have
much more complicated social
networks that have farther
reach, I think an
ARG could be neat.
To be following in real time,
it's not really a spectator
sport like what you're talking
about, but it is a place where
it sort of explodes online.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we're out of
time, but I'm going to add
my final thought, because I'm
the emcee and I get to do
that, which is that I feel like,
with the exception of
maybe world championships--
I can watch a "League of
Legends" game; I don't really
know who to root for-- it's
a group of three guys.
It's along with making
connections with the players,
but I also think these guys need
to just start creating
regional affiliations.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Totally.
TODD KERPELMAN: I can go
to any baseball game--
if I didn't know baseball, I
could still go to a baseball
game and know, well, I'm going
to root for the team that
represents my city.
Like, you can just do that.
DAN GALPIN: Like, you're going
to wear an orange panda hat.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm going to
wear an orange panda hat, and
look ridiculous.
And it's going to be OK,
because I'm from San
Francisco, and that's
the team I know I am
supposed to root for.
I feel like there's nothing
right now that connects me to
a particular "League of Legends"
team, unless, you
know, maybe it's the world
championships, and there
representing America.
DAN GALPIN: That's right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I
agree with you.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I do think
this comes to avatar
customization, too, which is
like if people are carrying
banners behind them, that really
tell these guys are on
your side, and these guys are on
the other side, I think all
of this stuff is about
signalling to the player
what's going on.
And anytime you're dealing with
cameras, anytime you're
dealing with spectators,
what's going on is
really hard to tell.
Only games that are analogs of
actual sports have already
figured that out.
Basketball games and football
games really have
that figured out.
Can you imagine--
it would be really cool to
watch a spectator game of
"Splintercell," maybe.
Or maybe it would
just be a lot of
watching people not moving.
TODD KERPELMAN: A lot of people
watching people wait.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
let's move on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sorry, it's
fun talking about that.
DAN GALPIN: Speaking
of length--
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes,
we were kind of--
so this was a question
that Colt proposed.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ah, yes,
that question.
TODD KERPELMAN: And he proposed
the question, and
then he didn't show
up for this.
WOLFF DOBSON: At last
minute, I might add.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, so--
DAN GALPIN: The audacity
of that person--
WOLFF DOBSON: The Udac-- zing!
TODD KERPELMAN: So, the question
he was asking is, in
the modern gaming era, when
is a game too long?
I think the point he's trying
to make is maybe now that
we're all kind of playing on
phones and tablets and that
sort of thing, gaming sessions
should be shorter.
Or that would be
the more ideal.
And I guess because John is
adjusting his mic, we'll start
again with--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right,
hey, here we go.
It's not the length of the
game that matters.
It's how long it takes you
to get in and out.
I would love to play a very
long game that takes--
WOLFF DOBSON: Sorry.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: --that I could
play on my phone, but if it
takes a minute to launch
the game--
that in something like a
10 minute time window
of playing the game--
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I think
this is a huge deal with
mobile gaming.
I always thought this was an
incredible weakness of the
PSP, was waiting for that
disc to spin up.
The joke was always that my DS
is a great thing to do while
I'm waiting for my
PSP to boot.
TODD KERPELMAN: I've never
heard that joke.
That's funny.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it's true.
WOLFF DOBSON: It was
true for me, too.
TODD KERPELMAN: But we
still like you, Sony.
WOLFF DOBSON: I love you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You know,
I've been playing
"X-Com" a lot lately.
And sometimes I have 30 minutes
to play this game.
And that's enough to play
a short mission.
But five minutes of that is
spent booting into the game.
It's turning the PS3 on and then
seeing all of the logos
for all of the middleware.
WOLFF DOBSON: I was going to
say, you know what we need?
More animated logos
at the beginning.
Especially games that are
licensed, so you have to have
like three licensees, and then
the-- ah, it's awesome.
I love that.
DAN GALPIN: One of my greatest
pet peeves are people who do
mobile games, and the mobile
game insists on playing at
least two or three videos.
And in some gaming worlds, they
might actually be doing
something, like loading things
during the videos.
But invariably, they're doing
nothing while those videos are
playing, and the user is just
saying, I just want to get
into the game, so I can have my
five minutes of gameplay.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, show me as
many of your animated logos
as you want, so long as you're
actually loading my saved game
while you're doing it.
DAN GALPIN: And the worst
thing-- and the other thing is
that, in terms of mobile gaming,
you just want to be
exactly where you left off
as quickly as possible.
WOLFF DOBSON: Colt says games
should be links, links.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I like this
cartoonization of Colt.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's very easy.
TODD KERPELMAN: i feel like
the puppet's had more
insightful comments
so far then--
DAN GALPIN: I was going
to say, Colt, what
big glasses you have.
TODD KERPELMAN: You're
invited back.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh boy,
oh boy, oh boy.
DAN GALPIN: OK, so
where was I?
So to me, I like the genius of
something like "Angry Birds."
And I went back and
took a long look.
Why was this game such a crazy,
breakout success?
I had played games with
almost the exact
same gameplay before.
But it was you get in fast,
you get out fast.
The levels--
you feel a sense of
accomplishment quickly.
Like a level in "Angry Birds," a
lot of them take 30 seconds,
a minute to complete.
Boom, I've accomplished
something.
I've made some progression.
But yet, to actually get through
the entire thing is a
long slog of an experience.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, it's
a relationship.
And there's good data that the
longer people interact with
your game--
I mean, it's sort of obvious,
but you can actually see it.
The longer people interact with
your game, the more they
talk about it, the more they
share it with their friends,
the bigger the viral hit of
your game is going to be.
This is why "Dark Souls"
takes a long time
to get through that.
Games that you fire and forget,
and you're over with
in three minutes make a
big splash for a week.
And then everyone's playing
them, and it's over.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, it's
a slow burn of a game.
TODD KERPELMAN: So Daniel, as
our Android expert, do you
actually have data on the
average play session time that
people typically spend
with games?
DAN GALPIN: It's funny
that you--
we don't.
And that's partially because
on Android we don't
track what people do.
That's just that simple.
We don't have any hooks in to
see what people are doing.
I'd love to know that, though.
TODD KERPELMAN: Could you guys
email us and just let us know
constantly?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We
don't spy on you.
DAN GALPIN: If some
developer wants to
tell me, that's great.
But we actually don't track any
usage on Android, so we
don't really know.
We only know when someone
installs something and when
someone uninstalls something,
essentially.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean, the game
developers themselves are
annotating the game with
analytics all over the place,
you'd hope.
And If you aren't,
please do so.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
Help us.
TODD KERPELMAN: And if you
are a game developer, put
something in the comments right
now, and maybe Lewis
will tell us.
DAN GALPIN: And from what
I gather from the game
companies, though, it really
depends on the game.
There are games that appeal to
a really hardcore gamer.
The sessions are longer.
By definition they're longer,
especially since a lot of them
don't have a good way of pausing
in the middle of the
action, necessarily.
So obviously those game times
are going to be very long.
Something like "Angry Birds,"
it's very short.
I think that Rovio has actually
released data about
how long the average "Angry
Birds" session is.
And actually, it was longer
than I expected.
But I think that's simply
because the game is so
ridiculously addictive.
But yeah, I think there's no
limit to the length of a game.
In fact, what we've seen is that
the games that are most
successful are the games that
build a franchise, the games
that continue to add and
add and add content.
As long as the content has value
and the consumer feels
like they're not just rolling
through the same mechanics
over and over and over again,
they'll play out a long way in
terms of content.
So I don't think there's any
such thing as a game that's
too long, certainly.
There is a game that's too large
in terms of how much
space it takes up
on the device.
WOLFF DOBSON: There are games
that are too long, though.
There are definitely games that
overstay their welcome,
but that's much more about the
artistic side, where it's
like, you know I haven't done
anything new in a while.
This plot went off the rails.
TODD KERPELMAN: This level
feels like padding.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think Dan
was getting at that.
Oftentimes I'll play game.
And the first half an
hour, I'm loving it.
And then I'm like, hey, you know
what, this half hour just
feels like I'm doing the
same thing again
and again and again.
TODD KERPELMAN: We're going to
move on, but we do have a-- is
there a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you guys were
talking about platforms and
you brought up PSP and all
these different things.
WOLFF DOBSON: Chrome.
AUDIENCE: And there's the new
Wii U. We haven't talked about
the Wii U, yet.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, Pedro was asking,
do you find that
today's platforms, Xbox, PSP,
all of the ones that are out
there-- are they sufficient
for today's market?
Will the Wii U do something
brand new?
And what's missing?
I just want to get your take on
the console market today.
TODD KERPELMAN: Good
question, Pedro.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All
right, Pedro.
So I have a Wii U, and--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh,
wow, how is it?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's great.
I have "Nintendo Land" and
"Mario." And so "Mario,"
everyone knows what you're
getting when you buy "Mario."
But "Nintendo Land" actually
has some really interesting
gameplay ideas.
And I would consider that it's
not technically new in that
it's groundbreaking, but it's
never been attempted to be
done on this scale and to this
mainstream audience, which is
asymmetrical gaming.
One of the games that we keep
playing over and over and over
again is "Luigi's Mansion,"
or something like that.
And it's not the old "Luigi's
Mansion." It's essentially a
mini game where the player with
the tablet is a ghost and
is trying to take down everyone
who's looking for them.
The other players are using the
old Wii-mote controllers.
DAN GALPIN: So it's
"Splinter Cell."
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't know.
Not exactly.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mario
"Splinter Cell."
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the other
players have the flashlight,
and if they point it at the
ghost, which they can't see on
the television, the ghost lights
up and takes damage.
And then when the ghost
gets down to zero
health, game over.
WOLFF DOBSON: But the flashlight
has some timer on
it, or something.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The flashlight
has batteries which will
appear randomly.
But that's a great trap
for the ghost.
WOLFF DOBSON: They're like
"X-Files" flashlights that are
only this wide, no matter how
dangerous the thing is.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, yes.
It doesn't matter.
It's very targeted.
But that game is ridiculously
fun because of the extra
information that the ghost
player has, which is you can
see everything.
You can see where every player
is, what's going on, do they
need batteries, where the
battery is going to be.
And so you can be kind of
lurking around a corner.
And they're flashing around
and shaking everywhere.
It's like, they go for the
battery, you take them down.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're
like, I like games
where I get to lurk.
Lurking is good.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then the
other players try and
resuscitate them, so it's
this weird dynamic.
WOLFF DOBSON: I like games where
there's a ditch, where
my friends are trying to pull
themselves back to life.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's this week
dynamic where whoever is the
most powerful in the game is
always going back and forth.
And it's all built around this
idea that one person who's
playing the game has extra
information, extra knowledge
which gives them an edge, but
still the game is balanced.
WOLFF DOBSON: I've seen--
there have been like source
engine mods that had games
like that, where one guy can
run up walls and everybody
else can't, and things
like that.
I think that kind of game
is pretty cool.
DAN GALPIN: I think the great
thing about that kind of
device is really just the
ability to do a lot of things.
You can do a lot of the same
thing with any computer and
any kind of second screen
device, whether that's an
Android device or a Chromebook,
or whatever you
might have.
But what's great about that
is that it makes it
absolutely real time.
I mean the technology there is
that your display is coming
off of the Wii U, and so it is
as fast as it can transmit the
bits over the air.
And that, to me, is really the
only difference between that
and actually just having a
tablet sitting next to your
console, is just how real
time you can do it.
WOLFF DOBSON: So this goes
back to our latency
conversation.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's not only
latency, because it's keeping
the two in sync.
Like, hey, I've got a tablet,
and I can have a second screen
experience, but how do they
synchronize with each other?
How does the game actually
initiate where-- since it's
all running on the Wii U,
they're just in sync
automatically.
DAN GALPIN: One of the things
that I'm really excited about
with the latest version of
Android is we actually finally
enabled something that I've
wanted for a long time, which
is true multi display.
So today, in theory, you could
actually hook up true multiple
displays coming off of a
single Android device.
WOLFF DOBSON: So are you
chaining it with cables?
Or how does that work?
DAN GALPIN: Well, on something
like the Nexus 4, you actually
can do it over Mirror Cast.
You can do it over
Wi-Fi Direct.
And that display is completely
driven by that device.
It's just a stream that
comes off of it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think that's
how the Wii U operates.
DAN GALPIN: That actually is.
It's very similar.
The only thing about the Wii U
is that they've customized it
so that they have minimal
latency and all of that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Its crazy
how low latency is.
I've held it and been watching
the game on the TV and on the
tablet, and they're
just mirrored.
It's imperceivable to me.
WOLFF DOBSON: Going back
to latency-- oh sorry.
TODD KERPELMAN: Going back, I
was going to tie it back to
our original question of what
are consoles missing.
That seems like a
nice feature.
I don't know if that's the--
WOLFF DOBSON: I will say on
the Dreamcast, we had the
second screen right
there, my friend.
DAN GALPIN: I remember back when
the Dreamcast was around.
WOLFF DOBSON: Back in my day.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It was 16
columns by 16 columns.
DAN GALPIN: I was amazed at how
many different gameplay
experiences that enabled,
though.
Like, the little Dreamcast,
everything from little
mini-games that you would
do on those things.
Sometimes you would even take
it away from the console.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, yeah.
The little Chaos things from
"Sonic Adventure."
TODD KERPELMAN: They were great,
except the battery
lasted about, like--
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: That, and then
they added that huge noise
whenever it turns on, saying
my battery is dead.
And of course, I still
have my Dreamcast.
You plug it in 12 years later,
and it's like, I don't even
know if I can buy a
battery for this.
And it's going, beep, save me.
No, but it is interesting.
And I think--
I mean, going forward in time
a little bit, from when
dinosaurs roamed the earth--
there was also "Four Swords,"
"Zelda, Four Swords," where
you plugged in.
It was such an expensive
thing to set up.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: But when you
did, it was so cool.
We played a ton of that,
where you have a
GameCube and then four--
TODD KERPELMAN: Four GBAs.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, Game Boy
Advances hooked up to it.
And I think, actually, when you
think about where we came
from, like--
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: They have
absolutely been interested in
this for a long time.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, I'm
going to stop us and move on
to, I guess, what will be our
last question, which is--
WOLFF DOBSON: Chrome.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Chrome
is the answer.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
I'm pretty sure.
Actually, Dan, I don't know if
you've actually worked in the
games industry.
DAN GALPIN: No.
TODD KERPELMAN: No.
I have no good answer
to this question.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
All right, so you're not
allowed to answer.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ah, ah,
I worked for years.
TODD KERPELMAN: I know everyone
else, and Puppet Colt--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: --has worked
in the games industry.
We might have people who
are the industry--
WOLFF DOBSON: I worked
my paws to the bone.
TODD KERPELMAN: But we might
also have people who are
wondering, hey, how do I get
into the games industry?
WOLFF DOBSON: I worked
on the "paws" menu.
Ah.
Oh, no.
DAN GALPIN: Colt--
WOLFF DOBSON: It
had to happen.
DAN GALPIN: --what big
eyes you have.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
was funny.
DAN GALPIN: Sorry, go on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sorry.
TODD KERPELMAN: That was
funny, the "paws" menu.
All right, so how
did you get your
jobs in the game industry?
What advice do you have for
people today that are looking
to get into the industry?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I went about
it in, I think, the most
difficult way possible, because
I got a PhD in AI and
then worked on weird
post-doc stuff.
And then I was like, you
know what, I'm tired
of the public sector.
Let's try the private sector.
And I sent my resume in
to a recruiter that I
found on the internet.
I did it about as badly as
you could possibly do it.
However, then working with the
recruiter, I think the main
thing that especially AAA
developers are looking for are
people who can code.
I mean, if you want to be an
artist, there's a whole other
conversation.
And actually, we should put that
on our Five For Five at
some point, too, paths in that
aren't just developer, like
straight coder.
But you need to be
able to code.
You're going to be tested.
You're going to be
given a test.
You gotta know this stuff, just
because there's so many
people who want to develop
games, because it's fun and
it's neat, and it's got
a lot of glamour.
Sort of.
DAN GALPIN: Perceived glamour.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Remember all
those red carpet parties we
used to go to?
WOLFF DOBSON: Actually,
I went to one.
I went to an actual
red carpet.
TODD KERPELMAN: Really?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, when we
launched the Dreamcast-- once.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: E3 used
to be pretty--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, and
E3 is like fun.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
all right, yeah.
E3's--
WOLFF DOBSON: But yeah, if you
want to go to parties, you
should pick a different
industry.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So totally to
your point, how I got into the
games industry was, in grad
school I wrote a real-time 3D
collision detection and physics
engine that was
comparable to Bullet
and Havoc.
And then Erwin Coumans hired me
to work at PlayStation to
optimize Bullet for the PS3.
And that was exactly it.
Like, I just wrote an actual
physics engine from nuts to
bolts, soups to nuts,
or whatever.
WOLFF DOBSON: This
is a big deal.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And
that was it.
It was like, here's
my portfolio.
It's a fully working engine.
WOLFF DOBSON: And if you're
looking for engine work--
I mean, you should build
the things that you
want to work on.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF DOBSON: Although I will
say, you may end up working on
things that you didn't know--
I mean, my first
job was sports.
TODD KERPELMAN: You will
end up working on
things almost certainly.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, almost
certainly you're going to end
up not really doing
what you want.
But the advice that I give--
WOLFF DOBSON: Welcome
to life, kids.
You're not gonna do
what you want.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Get ready
for disappointment.
WOLFF DOBSON: Life from here
is nothing but pain.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The advice I
give to everyone who asks this
question is write the engine.
Like, if you want
to be an engine
engineer, write an engine.
In your own time, by yourself,
do the hard work, and you'll
get a job so easily.
If you just show up with a
resume like, hey, I graduated
with a computer science degree
and I want to write a game
engine, good luck.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, the thing
is, in the game industry,
you're looking for builders.
You're looking for people who,
if you leave them alone in a
room with a laptop, they will
start building a game.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly.
WOLFF DOBSON: When I was
interviewing other developers,
this is what I looked at,
like are you builder?
Are you the kind
of person who--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I would always
ask, what software have you
written in your spare time?
It's the biggest indicator.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
I mean, some people have got
really, really interesting and
active outside-of-work lives,
which generally aren't game
developers.
But sometimes there's
some slack there.
It's like, oh yeah, I do like
free climbing up Half Dome
every weekend.
It's like, OK, fine,
that's pretty cool.
But otherwise it's like, yeah,
you should be building.
You're not just like a huge
player, you're a builder.
Gametribe games are a great
way to get into
the groove of that.
But long-term projects
are also really good.
Also, looking for ideas.
If you built--
I built "Space Invaders," and
you're like, well, "Space
Invaders" is cool, but we've
all kind of played it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: See, but
that's not on the
scale that's required.
Like, high-end--
WOLFF DOBSON: Depending on
what you want to do.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: --console gaming
requires programmers of
a very high skill level.
And they have to be
able to build.
It's not enough to be like, oh,
in my spare time I built
"Space Invaders." You have to
build a real-time 3D engine
with the latest algorithms.
And then you're going
to get a job.
WOLFF DOBSON: You disagree
a little there.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I mean, a little.
Because there's very clearly
jobs in the industry that
don't require writing game
engines from scratch.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I was gonna
say that the hardest thing
about game engines is that it's
very hard to find people
who've actually worked on the
core of them, because the vast
majority of people who work on
games never touch the engine.
They're working on all of the
stuff around it, whether it's
tools, or whether it is simply
on creating content.
I mean, there are some people
who have gotten jobs in the
game industry just because
they've created the most
awesome mod for some engine,
for example.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mods are an
interesting way in.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
mods are actually--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Was it
"Counter-Strike?" Didn't they
get hired by--
WOLFF DOBSON: Gooseman?
Is that his name?
Something like that.
Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: They got
bought by Valve, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Way
back in the day.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
And there are other people who
build really great mods.
I remember hiring people,
especially people who were
coming from less traditional
CS backgrounds.
It's like, oh, but you were huge
into the modding scene.
It's clear what work
you're doing.
If you want to be a level
designer, making mods is
absolutely the way to go.
Because I mean, that's basically
your job when you're
a level designer, is take some
guy's engine and change it so
it does the thing that
you want to do.
So yeah, learn to code, kids.
No.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Build.
WOLFF DOBSON: But more than
learning to code--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
the best way to
put it is to build.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
learn to build.
Learn to build things
that are-- and also
things that are finished.
I mean, it's a terrible thing
to say because it's really
easy to make a bunch of things
that aren't finished.
Or at least get to the
point at which they
make a clear demo.
And I think that's also--
and there's a maturity to
setting out to building
projects that requires you to
have that kind of, like, the
demo looks like this and I'm
going to get there in three
weeks kind of thing, versus, I'm
just gonna build an engine
and see what comes out.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean,
building an engine is a trap.
And it's a huge time sink.
WOLFF DOBSON: It is
a huge time sink.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Because you
could just keep iterating on
different engine subsystems over
and over and over again--
and improving them, but
what's to show, right?
It's a lot of fun, but
you have to have
a compelling demo.
You want to have the demo drive
the engine, not the
other way around.
WOLFF DOBSON: I worked on an
indie game for a while, and I
got way into the hat maker.
And it wasn't a 3D game.
It was a 2D game.
But I had these little anime
guys, and they all wore hats.
And then I had to attach the
hat, and I had all these
attachment points in an XML
format and a tool where you
could lay out all
the hat points.
And then the hats themselves
could rock back and forth as
they walked.
And then I eventually added
particle emitter
points on the hats.
I was, like, two months
into this.
And I was like, wait a
minute, this adds no
value to this game.
DAN GALPIN: But the excitement
about that kind of feature,
though, is exactly why--
TODD KERPELMAN: That's why
you need a producer.
So if you want to
be a producer--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
Yeah, you go find people like
Wolff and tell him to stop
working on damn hats.
TODD KERPELMAN: I mean, and
that's a good skill.
It's like, you can keep working
on a game forever.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: And sort of
knowing where to get the most
bang for your buck, knowing how
to prioritize, knowing,
hey, this is actually a point
where you can release it on
Kongregate as our finished game
or something like that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or unfinished
game, but get it out there.
I mean, the other habit--
and it is an absolutely natural
thing to do, and it's
true of every kind of art,
including games-- is not
releasing it because
it isn't perfect.
Ain't going to happen.
I can tell you from shipping
AAA games, they're
chock-a-block with things that
you wish you could fix.
And you just ship them, because
the money's over.
You gotta get out of there.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, after
being in the games industry
for a while, I was kind of
disturbed by how shoddy these
games actually are, but how
well they come off in the
final form.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, you spend
your time on the things people
do, and just don't look
behind that thing.
Don't try to balance--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I would spend
time with the games a month
before they come out and I'd
be like, holy crap, this--
and then it's just in that
final month, it's
just, uh, we got it.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's because
you don't sleep during that
entire month.
And all you do is you
crank [INAUDIBLE].
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
that's true.
DAN GALPIN: And I think,
actually, it depends on the
kind of game, too.
I think some of the most
polished games out there are
some of these puzzle games,
where that initial experience,
because that puzzle experience
doesn't necessarily change all
that much, it's very, very
focused [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and that's
a good producer and level
design thing, too.
You know, come up with a puzzle
structure and then
build and build amazing
levels out of that.
That's gonna get attention.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You build
your tools that
allow you to very quickly--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, tools.
And of course, every hour you're
spending on tools to
build the level, you're
thinking, I'm not
shipping this game.
But of course, there's some--
DAN GALPIN: And you can
go too far that way.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN GALPIN: And then you're
selling Unity.
That's what happens.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and that
happens to game companies,
where they turn into tools
companies, because it turns
out they're really good at
making tools and they're not
so good at shipping
things on time.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so we are way over--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm not saying
that about any particular
thing, just to be sure.
TODD KERPELMAN: --on
that subject.
And we've actually
used up our time.
So we're going to finish
with a quick round of
what are you playing.
So I feel like I've
been starting with
Wolff most of the time.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, you gotta
start over there.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I gotta start
with John, who's gonna
say "X-Com."
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, I've been
playing the Wii U. But in
particular, my obsession with
"Scramble with Friends" has
kicked back up.
I'm now top 3% globally.
DAN GALPIN: Wow.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I like
that game too much.
DAN GALPIN: Are you using--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What's
great about it is
that it's three minutes.
For one round is
three minutes.
So I can very easily sneak
it in anywhere.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
WOLFF DOBSON: What
about you, Dan?
TODD KERPELMAN: Mr. Galpin?
DAN GALPIN: Huh.
That's a good question.
Actually, the last
thing I played an
incredible amount of--
I'll say right now, "Expendable
Rearmed." I was
actually really thrilled
that that came
out on Android again.
WOLFF DOBSON: Say that again.
DAN GALPIN: "Expendable
Rearmed."
WOLFF DOBSON: "Expendable
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
It just came out again.
It was a Dreamcast game.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh my god.
"Expendable."
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
and it's now--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, wow.
DAN GALPIN: And it's now--
WOLFF DOBSON: Back when
dinosaurs roamed the earth.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
Freaking Dreamcast.
Developers just recently brought
it to Android, and I'm
really happy with it.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think that's
an incredible trend, by the
way, of bringing
some of these--
especially lesser-known
titles.
"Expendable" was fun, as
it actually turns out.
I mean, there were things you
would do to it, and of course
they've had time to
do that to it.
And then, yeah, I've seen a
bunch of PlayStation 2 ports
appear on Android and been like,
oh wow, oh yeah, that
was awesome.
People should totally
play that.
DAN GALPIN: I was excited. "Jet
Set Radio" just came out
for Android, speaking
of blasts from
the Dreamcast past.
But yeah, "Expendable" is
probably the one I'm playing
the most now.
TODD KERPELMAN: So let's see,
obviously "Skyrim." Although I
reached a point yesterday--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Still?
TODD KERPELMAN: --where
I was like--
WOLFF DOBSON: "Skyrim."
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Still
"Skyrim?"
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, still.
Well, it's a long game, and I
don't really have a lot of
hours in the day.
WOLFF DOBSON: Baby.
TODD KERPELMAN: But I reached
a point yesterday where I'm
like, you know, I think I can
probably take a break and play
something else and come
back to it later.
WOLFF DOBSON: I am tired of
talking to these people.
I would like to do
something else.
TODD KERPELMAN: A little
bit of that.
I'm really tired
of the guards.
I hate the guards.
So I actually have sort of been
playing a whole slew of
mobile games, just
trying them out.
I don't always play on iOS
devices, but when I do, I
enjoy "Letterpress." That's
actually a fun game.
It's kind of a word
competitive game.
It's a little stressful,
because it is awfully
competitive.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's because
John's playing it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Not yet.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
surprisingly, I have found
that out of the decorator games,
like build-up-your-city
ones, the licensed ones--
normally you say licensed game,
oh, maybe stay away.
I feel like the licensed
ones have all
been better than average.
Like, "Simpsons, Tapped
Out" is quite good.
The "My Little Pony" game is
much better than it has any
right to be.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, really?
TODD KERPELMAN: "The Littlest
Pet Shop" game,
very nice 3D models.
I was very impressed
with all of those.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm
curious why you--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
I was gonna say--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: --decided to
buy "My Little Ponies."
WOLFF DOBSON: --you have
a long list of
these sorts of games.
Are you--
TODD KERPELMAN: I am not.
No, really.
I realized I haven't played
mobile games in a while.
I'm just gonna through
the top 20 list and
give them all a try.
So that's kind of what
I've been doing.
AUDIENCE: Todd, when you
mentioned "My Little Pony,"
all of our viewers
dropped off.
So nobody--
TODD KERPELMAN: I want to make
it clear, I'm not a brony.
WOLFF DOBSON: Brony.
TODD KERPELMAN: I am not.
I've never seen the show.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Wait, brony?
WOLFF DOBSON: Brony.
DAN GALPIN: So I will say, you
don't know about bronies?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No.
DAN GALPIN: The other game that
I got completely wrapped
into this last week was
"Dominion" online.
I actually--
WOLFF DOBSON: Which
version of it?
DAN GALPIN: It's the Goko.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's tight.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
fantastic.
DAN GALPIN: It's so,
so well done.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I believe
it is in HTML, isn't it?
WOLFF DOBSON: Chrome.
DAN GALPIN: It runs
fine on Chrome.
I've got it right here
on my Chromebook.
WOLFF DOBSON: I picked
up the--
I picked up the Humble Bundle
for Android, and I started
playing "Missionarium," which
is an older model, but it
checks out.
It's a Flash game.
It's a point-and-click
adventure.
I had poked at it back when
it was in Flash in
the browser, I think.
And I was like, oh,
this is neat.
I don't have time to do this.
Wander away.
And then I put it on my Nexus
7, and I was playing it.
And I started playing it at
midnight, thinking, well,
these point-and-click adventures
are sure gonna put
me to sleep.
Then, like, an hour and 15
minutes later, I'm like, I
have to stop clicking.
But it's clever in 100
ways, beautiful art.
One interesting thing about
it, especially when you
compare it to another thing
that came in the Humble
Bundle, which was the "Sword and
Sworcery," the #sworcery.
Clever naming, by the way,
putting the hash at the
beginning--
alphabetization, excellent
choice.
Good work.
But the "Sword and Sworcery"
was designed around touch
interfaces, so everything's
kind of big.
When you click on something, you
get the little ring around
it, and you do the stuff.
It's like, oh, I know
what I'm doing.
But "Missionarium," since it
wasn't designed around touch
interfaces at first--
although it plays just fine,
and you should try it--
there are moments where you're
like, I can't see what I'm
doing, because everything's
too small, and
my finger's so big.
I need one of those-- like, in
Korea, there's that particular
brand of sausage you use as a
stylus because it has the
right capacitance for
a capacitive stream.
This is a real thing.
I'm not making this up.
Yeah, I need a stylus or
something to play it just
right, although I'm totally
getting through it.
It's fine.
But it's an interesting thing.
I didn't realize that was a
design consideration when
porting things from mouse
pointer to touch.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
And--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm playing
Chrome games.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thank
you, Wolff puppet.
WOLFF DOBSON: No problem.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I believe
with that, we are done.
We're wrapped up.
So thank you very much for
watching, those of you that
are still watching.
WOLFF DOBSON: Bye.
TODD KERPELMAN: Maybe
next week--
well, let's take a vote and
decide whether you prefer the
puppet Colt or the
actual Colt.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
WOLFF DOBSON: Puppet
Colt, Puppet Colt.
DAN GALPIN: I think we should
all have puppets next week.
TODD KERPELMAN: And whoever
wins, that's who we'll invite
back next time.
So thank you very much.
And we will see you
in a couple weeks.
WOLFF DOBSON: Bye.
DAN GALPIN: Bye.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Bye.
DAN GALPIN: Ciao.